second hour we will play that interview
but first off
we have one of our favorites here today
with us rachel bitkoffer everyone knows
rachel uh she she she's
she's always on twitter pounding
messaging messaging messaging messaging
and the one thing i want to do is i want
to show rachel this video
of this lieutenant governor
trying trying to wipe the fascism off of
her
as this local reporter
uh uh asked her questions in in
fantastic style and and all journalists
can learn a lesson out there rachel how
are you
i'm great tony as you know i've chosen
today to live stream from my favorite
location in eugene skinner's butte which
is this beautiful beautiful view that
you guys see yeah look at that i would
panoramic it but i figure it's enough
you guys have a train whistle in the
background to deal with even better even
better to set the scene you know we we
love when you do from the pickup truck
but i don't know this this may one up
the pickup truck rachel i think so man i
gotta tell you i didn't come up here
near enough before i was forced into
expatting for grad school and it's not a
mistake i'll be making twice tony you'll
be going back is what you're saying yep
that's awesome it is a great view this
is a great view there so how are you
feeling i know you had a trip to texas
here recently uh you were talking about
that on twitter is there anything you'd
like to tell us about that trip from
texas
yeah you know it's always nice to go to
the republic of texas you know it's like
you know second second grounds zero of
the gop state level like fascists
takeover of a competitive state they're
much more condensed in places where
gnome has you know like south dakota
north dakota
idaho like they're actually even worse
up in those places but nobody gives a
[ __ ] because no one lives there right uh
florida texas ground zero of covid uh
genocide basically so i went down there
to try to light a fire into the
progressive community and explain to
them look everything you're doing down
here in texas matters insofar as trying
to set a national narrative that turns
2022 a referendum on the gop right and
if there's one person that gets this
referendum it's better as a as a
campaigner he's you know the campaign is
definitely you know tying it all to
this is what happens when republicans
are in charge of your health wealth and
safety and that's the strategy that
everyone needs to be using in their
messaging right now
he is he he does seem to be striking
chords down there um i know it's going
to be an uphill battle and we talked
about the uphill battle for him before
but i mean the g the gqp in texas the
fascists in texas are basically handing
this to the democrats uh rather they
know it or not i mean they're they're
they they passed the the bounty hunter
law and now they're they're floating a
law that would make it
uh
to where the texas could give a a person
who would have even uh a medical
procedure that would save their life
to kill them these are the pro-life
people these are the right to life right
exactly right and and you know that
these these issues coming out of texas
coming out of florida they're absolutely
um ripe for wedging uh all it takes is a
design
it's not hard to wedge an issue if you
know how to do it and i do i've studied
gop anatomy for a long time
um and we need to you know
let people understand these risks
personal risk not something that might
happen to a trans child over there right
they're using the state the power of the
state government to weaponize child
protective services to come and
basically put political pressure on
people who want to accept their kids for
who they are right
even even just even just for someone to
have the thought and and to to try to
say hey i want to receive counseling for
these thoughts that i might be having
these feelings and i might be having
even just the simple care that the
actual counseling care of that would
trigger what they're talking about to
ostracize not just not just the people
who are having these thoughts but their
parents and their other siblings like to
totally ostracize him from society if
you don't understand what fascism is
maybe you should go all over to the
google machine and look it up that is
exact definition not only that they want
to take away women's liberty and then if
women and act on their liberty either in
texas or another state they want to give
them the death penalty these are
pro-lifers by the way dude and they also
want to give rapists the ability to
keep you from aborting a baby sue for
custody after they raped you i mean to
me that's a [ __ ] nightmare to be
honest with you as a rape survivor the
idea that i'd be forced to bear to term
my rapist baby and then share custody
with them hell [ __ ] no tony right
well did you see sorry trains going
there no that's okay did you see did you
see the uh there was a video from the
tennessee legislator where they're
talking about a bill um you know florida
wants to out texas texas texas wants to
out florida florida and now you have
tennessee you have missouri piling on uh
we've seen a bill floated in the
missouri legislature where they want to
make it illegal for a woman to even
leave the state of missouri to receive a
medical procedure um
we've seen a video in missouri where the
the person who's writing the bill that
makes it illegal for a woman to receive
a procedure for an eptopic pregnancy he
was asked do you even know what an
eptopic pregnancy is he's like nope
don't care don't give a [ __ ] why would i
care i'm not gonna get a i a man would
never have an eptopic pregnancy right so
what does he give a [ __ ] until his
daughter needs the surgery or is gonna
die right and then he'll be like oh [ __ ]
did i [ __ ] that up right like we can't
afford for every republican to have a
gay child or you know need a
abortion because of an ecotopic
pregnancy and what we do need to do is
make sure that norms the norms out there
because again if you hear me and tony
every day or even occasionally you are
not a normal person you are not a modal
american our job is as highly informed
and engaged individuals is to find a
mechanism by which we can convey this
collective narrative of gop government
onto normal people and make them fear
that change right you have to make
people fear change in 2022 and define it
as something that is going to endanger
them personally
well and i think i think also the other
thing that we have to do is try to find
a way to draw those wedges in between
what what is the old guard right the
thin veil fascism right what debts
deficits all that [ __ ] because they
never really truly believed any of this
and we now know this we have to find a
way to draw a wedge in between the old
guard thin veiled fascism and this
outright fascism that we have now and
make them make them fight amongst
themselves like they always make us
fight right we're always fighting over
is it fifteen dollars an hour eight
dollars an hour not me tony
dude
let them let them fight amongst
themselves and we can draw those wedges
by asking these questions to the what
wants to be the old guard that doesn't
want to say the quiet part out loud and
you know they're they're not with this
quiet part out loud make them answer for
the people who are saying the quiet part
out loud that's exactly right if we tie
all of them to it and define the whole
party as marjorie taylor green josh
halley ron desantis then these people
then finally have a vested interest in
controlling their own party one of the
big failures that we're suffering
through right now politically is the
inability of the republican party to
police itself in any capacity so if you
look at the cuomo scandal um you know
the democratic party was slow to respond
there's no [ __ ] doubt about that guys
but at the end of the day it responded
and pushed him out with a super majority
basically in new york state they didn't
do it because they had to do it they did
it because they had to do it for
for to maintain uh legitimacy in their
own caucus so and the gop had that
mechanism
as long back as like 2014. i remember
even this guy that's running for
missouri senate will probably be the
next senator to join holly in that two
in that two-person senate caucus is eric
greitens and he was pushed out of the
governorship from missouri for black
sexual blackmail okay and they at that
time the republican party still had
enough [ __ ] dignity to kick his ass
out okay
now he's the front-runner for the senate
and they will vote for him at the same
[ __ ] rates they voted for doug jones
down in alabama it doesn't matter what
these people do there's no internal
police now and that is incredibly
dangerous for america
well you know i know a bit about
eric greitens because i'm from missouri
and uh i actually have i actually have a
lot of
insight into eric greitens and i'd love
to share with you uh off air um that
maybe maybe we could talk about because
yeah i actually i actually uh uh know a
lot about eric greitens in the uh the
the absolute delusion that that guy
lives under um he is he's a frightening
individual yes but you know what you
know what you know what the gqp loves
they love frightening individuals
fascists fascists love scary people
they love scary people do scary things
no [ __ ] i mean look at what desantis has
done down there in florida man he's like
picked up trump's mannerisms he's rump
he's wearing these frumple looking
ensues with slowly increasingly
brilliant red in the tie
he he copies his cadence now he does he
does the hand side
[ __ ] dude it's [ __ ] up because it's so
stupid right it's somebody who's
studying goals and
you know all of this like propaganda
history it is but it's so stupid let me
tell you it will work it is working for
him it is going to work that's why he's
doing it
you know it as as much as he's really
trying hard it is a really shitty trump
impersonation by the way it's not that
great i mean he's getting better at it
but it really is one of the shittiest
trump impersonations i've seen but he is
but don't doubt desantis he's he's
banging up florida he's really trying
hard um to not only to not only uh hurt
floridians but to ostracize children
children in florida
and if you guys missed uh my partner
dougie crunched some numbers and we put
out this data uh it shows that florida's
death rate is seven times higher than
dc's okay so it's three times higher
than california's and basically the same
for new york and that's kind of a
problem guys like when you look when you
control for a post vaccine because keep
in mind the first wave of covid rushes
in kills a [ __ ] ton of people in the
urban metros that's march by the time it
starts to spread out to april that's
when the republican party's like [ __ ] it
we gotta reopen everything right so like
they reopen
it literally as the first wave is
peaking down in in florida and in
georgia and other places and that's why
we ended up with a wildfire infection
rate that we could never control
once vaccines come out though death is
frankly preventable i mean nine out of
ten people dying now are not vaccinated
so it's fairly preventable and they have
just let it rip i mean they they have
led their own constituency to their own
to to death and and we got to make ron
desantis answer for that
well i i agree and i think we can i
think we can tie all these republicans
together i want to show you this clip of
this idaho lieutenant governor um as as
she tries to explain
how she's not a nazi it's it's beautiful
it's beautiful let's let me play it here
real quick um it is a little long it's
about four minutes okay but but let's
let's play it i'll posit a few places
where we can commentate so let's listen
are you familiar with who puts this
event on like nick fuentes
i don't i don't know who he is i don't
i've never met him i don't know who he
is did you not look into it before you
decided to say okay like to find out i
mean his name is on it
well you know what nick fuentes i don't
as i said i don't know him i don't he's
never
this is really convenient right like
like oh he's just coffee boy right like
this is the coffee boy schtick like i
have no idea who he is never never heard
of the guy then why did you why did you
associate with him at all like
you google him right right right right
like a quick a quick search would you
would know that nick fuentes not only is
has anti-semitic ideas he isn't he is
the anti-semite yeah he is
he is it for them he's ground
[ __ ] zero dude
right right
not only that he he is palling around
with people like marjorie taylor green
lauren beaubert paul gozar for [ __ ]
sake oh she knows let's watch some more
that's right that's right
i've never met him i don't know i don't
know i don't know
where's the photo will come out this
weekend he says well there's photos
does not reflect on who i am or who the
thousands of others that are
participating in this
movement
you didn't bother to look up his name or
he didn't say that
you did look him up
you didn't that's not the question that
you asked me
he just asked
fuentes was and what he he what he's
talked about like what he thinks he has
said
i have since
since
last week not before yes
okay i guess the question is because you
if you've said well i'm only again it's
not fair
i mean
the mainstream media
you do this to conservatives all the
time but you don't do it to yourself
that oh this is this is beautiful
[ __ ] fascist are you stupid
you know it's it's crazy it's crazy to
think that
oh it's unfair it's unfair to ask the
question when i associate myself with a
no nazi with a known fascist a white
supremacist it is it is unfair for you
to ask me that question as the press
yeah
yeah it's not you doing your job it's
not a notable story you know it's like
come on dude these people just crack me
up man
i mean i mean but this is this is a a
good example of a local reporter
actually doing what you're supposed to
do and and really really getting at the
heart of the issue not what did you talk
about or no
right like look you are you are
associating with a nazi
right it's not it's it's not like
um i i i was i was small
and i was young when
george h.w bush ran for president the
first time and if you remember history
david duke if anyone's not familiar with
david duke he was a grand wizard of the
case and man bush was like disgusted
dude right
well the entire the entire republican
party basically basically
sent david duke out to pasture yes they
did for all intents and purposes said
yeah we cannot have this we cannot be
even close to have the stench of the kkk
on us like for for decades and decades
and decades with the democratic party
you know when you get this [ __ ] a lot
from the right they're like oh well the
democrats are the ones they were we're
the kkk like yeah but you're you're
you're negating all the history in
between no it's the same people tony
it's right exactly
exactly exactly the party allegiance
completely flips around in that
realignment guys but the [ __ ] people
are the same okay right southern white
conservatives
and the crazy part is
george h.w bush understood that in the
political landscape and knew that holy
[ __ ] i want those people's votes but i
can't let the rest of the country know
that i'm with david duke no no i want
david duke's vote i can't do that like
we won't win that way that was that was
the whole southern strategy oh no [ __ ]
i'm not gonna tell you like one of the
things that defines never trump i mean
it is it was the abject total [ __ ]
danger neon flashing signs of putting
somebody with trump's personality
failure of intellect self-control all of
those attributes that failed the
commander-in-chief test of the role of
the president that first freaked no
never trump out but the other component
is that people like jen rubin and tom
nichols and bill crystal are very vested
into racial pluralism okay
they joined into that coalition in the
1970s 1980s at a time period where the
party was very desperate to disassociate
itself with racial tension policies and
duke and you know so they they find
this as morally
um reprehensible as we do and thank god
because they're such important alley
allies right now in the fight to
maintain democracy here
well and and i've been saying this for a
long time is that that democrat the
democratic party the pro-democracy party
because that's really where we're at
right now we're at a point where the two
parties in our country one is for
democracy one is for autocracy one wants
a fascist state one wants democracy they
want freedom they want liberty and
and when when you're
when you're trying to decide which party
you're in right now it is really easy to
decide we should make that even easier
for these people and then you know
that's what we do with this new ad i
mean you know it's this is a frame that
i want to carry across the cycle and i
want everyone to be carrying this banner
it's not a straight pack frame autocracy
versus democracy autocracy republican
party democracy the democratic party it
ain't [ __ ] complicated right you got
your choice do you do you want a
dictatorship
or do you want liberty and then you got
to make that dictatorship feel personal
and you i mean you really do you got to
make it feel like it's not going to be
brown people or asian people or whatever
you know you got it it's unfortunate
democrats but the end of goddamn day
that white vote is really important and
white people are like any other group
they're going to be motivated mostly by
by descriptive representation and we
have to be making them personally fear
in suburban america what will happen to
them under republican control and their
children and it's not that hard because
the republicans are handing us this
stuff oh no [ __ ] it's not hard at all
tony i mean i want just can never
reiterate enough i know exactly how to
do it i can do it all [ __ ] day okay
call me because we need to do it
well i i'll tell you that
that i think i think in every state in
every republican-controlled state
they're going to keep out floriding
florida right and out texas out texas
texas and they're going to keep going
they're not going to stop and and i mean
we're at the point where they're talking
about giving people the death penalty
for receiving a medical procedure that's
we're not even to the bad part tony
don't you remember if they had found a
way to either win or steal 2020 and
stall trump in that if that coup had
succeeded
a big chunk of republicans conservative
you know voters and electeds had
invested in this cue phenomenon this qan
and phenomenon and the big portion of
their platform was re-elect truck trump
and then come after all of the people
all of the opposition jail them
and execute them i mean hell he's he's
saying he's saying it on stage
trump had a rally and all but said i'm
running in 2024 and what i want to do is
be a dictator like yes he's saying it
out loud
and all all the people out there
listening all the pro-democracy people
out there listening whether you think
you are a republican or a democrat or an
independent or moderate if you're for
democracy if you're for voting if you're
for not the government telling you what
the [ __ ] to do
just understand that 2022 is just as
important if not more important than
what 2024 will be and likely we will be
saying the same thing in 2024 that we're
saying right now that 2022 is the most
important in 2024 it will be we don't
win here tony we i mean how do you win
uh how do you have a 24 election with
these people okay these people who are
they've shown us who we are and i
[ __ ] believe them who they are and i
believe them we must believe them can
you imagine if they flip one of these
midwestern states michigan pennsylvania
wisconsin or all three and a new
republican governor of michigan
is asked to
you know administer freely and fairly
the 2024 presidential cycle [ __ ]
ain't gonna happen ain't gonna happen
right so so everything is 22. we have to
win right [ __ ] here right [ __ ] now
and and the way we do that is not just
not just the united states house and
senate those are the most important
races probably but we also have
governor's races and we have down ballot
races too where not only can we make
change on the federal level but these
states need our help these people in
these states pro-democracy and democracy
in these states need our help like those
in florida are like okay well if we
can't have a fascist state in the
federal government we'll just make one
here in the state of texas and the state
of florida and i and i think more and
more people in the state are
understanding that big government isn't
just the federal government like it's
not like they've always considered the
federal government the quote-unquote big
government but here uh in this in this
timeline in this crazy [ __ ] timeline
that we're in big government is is ron
desantis is greg abbott
is is uh eric schmidt in in missouri who
is the attorney general who kept suing
and suing and suing school boards to do
what they wanted to do
and and ron desantis and greg abbott
were suing local governments local
governments they've always said all
small governments how we want nope
that's not what they want yeah that's
not what they've ever wanted no true
conservative could ever endorse a crt
ban which is a point i made recently
to somebody very special we may talk
about again soon you know there's
literally it's anti-fucking thetical all
right if you're going to have the
government surveil citizens several
teachers teacher tip lines you know rape
victims getting sued by the rapist this
[ __ ] is big government as [ __ ] tony
right right well i mean it's it's
fascist it's big government it's it's
the exact big government that they
they've always been warning us about and
honestly maybe they were projecting
because it really does seem like they've
always been projecting doesn't mean yeah
there's no way
better than today's republican party
that's for sure dude that's that's right
that's right rachel i really do
appreciate you joining us and yeah let
me just give you guys the panoramic real
quick because i got you look at the view
look at this i want you guys to see
why i was so sad not to live here
for so so painfully long
isn't it nice
it's beautiful it's beautiful
thank you
thank you for joining us rachel we love
you guys i'm back next week we'll have
you on next week uh we'll be
and everyone stick around we'll be right
back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]